so recently Reckless joined t1s Academy
team and ever since people have been
wondering how the European Legend ended
up on the same org as Faker and more
importantly whether they'll ever play
together there was a time in League of
Legends history when Reckless and
fanatic were inseparable he was there
for so many of the EU org's most iconic
moments and lofty Heights most notably
in 2018 when he helped them to world's
final versus IG but after a couple of
rough Seasons domestically Reckless blew
up the internet by joining fanatic's
bitter rival G2 now less than a year
later the two would part ways after more
poor results that saw G2 failed to even
qualify for worlds Reckless moov to
French tier 2 Team Carman cor and soon
found success by winning the European
Masters spring split and then a year ago
things went full circle when recess
returned to fanatic but after an
unimpressive spring split this year
Reckless announced that he was roll
swapping to support and was benched now
it's important to know that he didn't
get benched because he swap rolls but
yeah it's not like fnatic were going to
give him a starting spot on a position
that he had no experience in anyway
Reckless spent the rest of this past
summer as an inactive member of Fanatics
Academy roster which got a lot of people
wondering what was next for this Legend
but nobody was expecting this during the
middle of Worlds it was reported that
Reckless was joining none other than t1s
Academy team in the lck challengers
league as their support alongside Dal
Guan pooby and smash with GBM as their
coach this was also backed up by
pictures on Twitter that appeared to
show Reckless at t1s facility already
wearing their colors so yeah T1 the
Korean Legends T1 the team that would go
on to win that worlds T1 the team that
has Faker Western fans have gotten very
used to seeing Korean talents head to
Europe or North America but that stream
never really flowed both ways which got
a lot of people wondering what prompted
such a move I don't even understand
what is happening is it because they
think that Reckless veteran status is
going to be able to benefit everyone or
do they think that like Reckless might
be the next carer of support there were
a few questions that everyone had first
of all could Reckless actually handle
such a big change in the official
announcement video from last week
Reckless talked about the challenges of
playing in a new country with the new
language and new teammates it's
undoubtedly a huge shift and then there
were questions about his performance
Reckless really play support at the
professional level sure it's an academy
team but it's t1s Academy team in the
lck it's not exactly going to be a walk
in the park now some fans have noticed
that he did hit Challenger on the Korean
server as support with a 66% win rate
and a particular liking for Jana
obviously solo qu isn't everything but
hitting Challenger in a particular role
in Korea is widely regarded as like the
next hardest thing to do outside of pro
play which he did with an almost 70% win
rate right now the next question is will
Reckless actually stay on T1 a lot of
people just viewed this as a big
marketing move how serious is reckless
and for that matter T1 well some Keeny
redditors did notice that Reckless is
contracted with T1 for 2 years that's
until 2025 that's a pretty high level of
commitment for an untested player from
another region of course if things don't
work out after the first year T1 could
always just release him that's not out
of the question but given the length of
the contract it does suggest that T1 and
Reckless are in this for the Long Haul
there's even been speculation that
Reckless is going to try and prove
himself to T1 for 2024 in a bid to try
and take carry a spot on the main roster
which brings us to our final question
will Reckless actually play with Faker
honestly stranger things have happened
in Esports listen if you told me a
couple years ago that Reckless would be
joining T1 as they and Faker won worlds
again after 7even years I'd be skeptical
but here we are I think a lot of Western
fans would love to see one of the
greatest EU talents of all time play
alongside the literal greatest player of
all time the main obstacle standing in
the way of all this seems to be that T1
already has like the best support of all
time in Cara I don't think that's
deniable obviously if Cara ever injures
himself gets sick or is otherwise
indisposed Reckless would be the next
one up to the plate and in that case yes
he would play with Faker but in the long
term car's contract with T1 doesn't
expire until the end of 2024 so I think
it's unlikely that Reckless is holding
his breath Cara is currently on a
championship winning team they all just
signed new contracts this could be T's
new Dynasty or it could not but I don't
think Reckless is going to hold out for
more than a year to wait and see if the
band will ever break up he said that he
has received offers from LEC teams in
the past but declined because he felt
like he wasn't at the right level yet
Perhaps a year on T1 Academy team might
change that and he'll take up an offer
to play on a main roster in Europe or
Korea but the quantity and quality of
these offers all depends on how things
go in this new year good choice by him
probably the best team he could join
just now the question is can he win it I
mean he has Poe my
goat just depends whether they can win
the league now or
not if they lose the league then no one
will care and he won't like like no one
will like turn their head but if he wins
the league everyone will turn their head
listen I'm sure the T1 isn't going to
miss the opportunity
to Market and create content around
Faker and Reckless it's a literal gift
from the heavens when trying to Market
to both Western and Eastern audiences
something that T1 has actually been
pretty good at in recent years but will
they be playing alongside one another
you might think it's impossible but
given everything that's already happened
in this story it might not be that crazy
well what was the last time that they
they it was like cuz they did that
entire series with uh Tyler one right
and Faker so like
I mean it's just a missed opportunity if
they don't do basically the same thing
with Reckless obviously it might be a
little different the shenanigans they
get up to they might not be going to
like a burger joint or whatever